ш але мені вас витян і дозволь the witcher
у серці править від нього з нашим
професіоналам днем ​​противника усвяти
сьогодні ви на передової боротьби за
українську на ніжність
на вас поклади надюша складне завдання
підготують і наших дітей і малий думай
but його якорем водяться мої будні про
його відома вийшов 1 і щоб не буде вже
адже різанина tasya сьогоднішнього дня
тому
важливо дітям до тенер лиж та знання api
2 туго ти їх та сміливі голови рішення
проблем готова критично переосмислити
це було приватні потоки інформації про
сьогоднішньому інформаційному suspense тві
якову туго тиса до змін без вас США
поза вами витяни і
реформа про святі мужі вигляд ніби я кит
не було чудове написання навчальний
програми чиї плани всі закони кількох
вчитель ви хапай викладати як або
спа середню до торкає сяду розуму
діти, що йдуть, зможе з правді піт вище
цій арці це навчання і ми в гатчині
вам за те що ви роботи шлях свій склад
днів і ж ротів не проти жаль
українська держава паркан бувало вірять у
читаємо і для нації, а крем і назвати шайн
поважив його завдання підняття соціального
статусу патологічних противників сам
цьому ж у нас тут нам у бюджетному
роті ми закладаємо у бізнесу не кричимо
несплати проти мешканця а їжі немає or if
несіть саду жваво жила його щоб
позиційного ти в 4 вище і сідай мама і
у полоні ти на його соціальний статус
народиться і рухи зарубіжні плати
Юрій антона натріть ну і теган і дістань
у али наша повага соціального статусу
вчителі
ми так вже за пропливав його проекті
закону право почету кроків Нікола та
адже хочу вам знову здоров'я творчості
над ним не
жадібному батьківщини вдавалися впав і
сильному вигорянню а в душі мати не
викреслити жерло любов'ю до дітей та до
професії десятому